Speaker 1: Let's go next to Kevin from Arlington,
Virginia, and see what's happening in Arlington.
Kevin, welcome to the program.
Speaker 2: Eric,
I have got a question about last week's speaker
vote, please. So, you know, with hindsight now
we know how it ended 15 ballots. Kevin McCarthy is
the speaker of the House. Hypothetically speaking,
the Democrats could have cut that off much
earlier. They don't even have to vote for
Kevin McCarthy. They could just vote present, not
show up. So my question is, do you think Democrats
ultimately benefited from holding the line for
Hakeem Jeffries and drawing out the process,
or was it really just a big waste of time?
Speaker 1: No. So here's the thing. Yes, Democrats
could have handed McCarthy the win earlier
by voting present. They lower the necessary
threshold in order to get the speakership. But
it's I think that it's just completely the wrong
framing. This is a Republican problem. It is
a Republican problem that they weren't able
to figure out until 15 votes went by how to get a
speaker elected. Democrats have no responsibility
to bail out Republicans. Republicans are not
united and Democrats are. Republicans are not
interested in actually governing, whereas
Democrats are. Republicans have shown in
the short time since Kevin McCarthy became speaker
they're not interested in even dealing with issues
that that help the American people. I know that
mathematically, Democrats could have acted to make
McCarthy the speaker more quickly, but I believe
it was waste. It's not a waste of time isn't even
the right framing. Democrats aren't in control.
Democrats wanted Hakeem Jeffries to be the
speaker, and there's no reason for Democrats to
become divorced from what they actually are, which
is united behind Jeffries. To artificially help
Kevin McCarthy. I think it would have been the
wrong move for Democrats to do that on principle.
Speaker 2: Okay, That makes sense. Thanks.
Speaker 1: All right, Kevin. Thank you.
There's Kevin from Arlington, Virginia. Yeah,
No, I. The debit number, please. I'm not
going to blame the Democrats on that one.